and um this is why we're so crazy about
crypto because in crypto it's sort of
this up right now because
like men men are so beta right
now that all you need is 3 or 5% of the
population to rise up and go but
they're doing everything they
can to run interceptions to keep
everyone asleep because if we if
if men like men are one thing one of the
smartest that like Andrew trade
ever said if men like they're they're
afraid of men getting together you have
you have a room of just men the
government pays attention so if you had
a lot of men just saying this
we ain't taking this and they go to
Capitol Hill and they go to Washington
shit'll change over night m